re ん
goo
はいみなさんこんにちは8位ばです今日は
ですね僕はここであの逆さになって踊っ
たりしませんけれどもあの皆さんと
ちょっとしたアイディアをご紹介したいと
思います
えっ今日は僕はですねあのどんな話を
しようかというとですね
あの理想的な自分たちの望む
豊かなます幸せな未来をですねあの実現
するそういった方法についてあのお話し
たいと思いますちょっと魔法みたいですよ
ねでこれは僕今研究をしていましてその
研究をしている中で出てきたことをご紹介
したいというふうに思うわけです
でですねえっとまぁ生あの先端的な研究な
んですけどもそれ自体はですね難しいこと
は全然なくて今日家に帰ってからあのまあ
こういったのお父さんお母さんと子供で
やることもできますしもう今日帰りの電車
の中ですることもできますまあそういった
ことでただとても重要なことなのでこの場
で皆さんと共有したいなというふうに思っ
ております
さてですねあの今日の話あの未来を実現
するということなんですけれども
はい未来未来というのはまだ来てないって
いうふうに日本語では書きますでまぁ今を
生きるって事はとても大切なんですけれど
もよくよく考えてみると僕らはこれから先
はずっと未来なので毎日未来を生きていく
ということになりますこれから死ぬまで
毎日毎日新しくくる未来を生きていくと
いうことになるわけです
でも僕らが普段
いろんな友達とかまあ家族や同僚会社の
同僚をいろんな人と話しているのはどちら
かというと未来の話と言うよりは今の話
だったり過去の話だったりするわけです
そういう中でこの未来をついて考えると
いうことはとても大切ででこの未来をつい
て考えるに僕の言葉をいつも思い出します
安蘭けいという人の言葉なんですけれども
未来を予測する最善の方法はそれを自ら
作ることであるというそういう言葉です
これはまぁほっておいてもですね今日今
から寝て明日を迎えても明日は来ます未来
はくるんですねでもそうやって傍観者の
ように自分と関係なくどっかから未来が
やってくるということではなくて自分が
自分らしくまああの未来を作っていくと
そういうことが重要だということがこの
メッセージに込められている理由
でこの安蘭けいという人はパーソナル
コンピューターの父と言われていまして僕
らが今の家でパソコンを使ったりしてます
ねで個人でパソコンを使っているというの
はもう何十年前にはあり得なかった光景
ですコンピューターは部屋ぐらい大きくて
ですねまあ軍事も目的だったりとか化学
計算のために使われていたその子だ第2
これからはコンピュータを一人一人が持っ
てそしてそのコンピューターを使って表現
をしたりあるいは何か勉強学びをしたり
ですねまあそういったことをしていく時代
になるんだとコミュニケーションしたり
ですねそういったことをしていこう
そういうためのパソコンのリア
コンピューターの利用があるんだってこと
をまあ言ってですねまぁそれを実現してき
たあの1人ということになるわけです
で僕らは社会を変えるっていうと大きく
大きな話になってしまいますが例えば自分
がこれから将来どういうふうに生きていく
のかあるいは自分たちの家族がどういう
ふうにあったら幸せなのかそういったこと
を考えて作っていくというのは僕たち
一人ひとりがやっていかなきゃいけない
ことだということになるわけです
で自分たちの関わり次第でその言い方にも
行ったりまあそうの悪い方向に行ったり
イマイチな方向に行ったりまあそういう
ことになるわけですねなので僕らはその
自分たちのよりより幸せな未来に向かって
何ができるかということを日々考えて実践
しているということになるわけです
ただその幸せというものがどうもボヤッ分
見し幸せな未来は
なりたいですよね幸せになりたいですよね
でも幸せて何勝手な人それぞれ違いますし
それぞれあの時期によっても違うかも知れ
ませんでとても曖昧なモヤっとしたものに
なっているはずです
あるいはそれをまだどっかの出てきた
キャッチコピーやスローガンのようなもの
で一言で言ったとしてもそれはちょっと高
の一部しか言っていないようなそうなって
しまうと
なのでそのモヤっとしていて曖昧なものを
一人で実現する時もやはりそれは難しい
ですしそれをまあたとえば家族みんなで
創ろうとかあるいはまあ自分たちの友達
同士グループで作ろうもしくは地域で
作ろう会社でつくろそういったことをして
いる場合には自分たちのその先にある未来
にある幸せがどんなものかということと
考えてあの実現していかなきゃいけないと
だけども曖昧なのでこれが皆それぞれ
ちょっとずつ違ったところ3考えていたり
ですね違うようなイメージを持っていると
だんだんだんだんですねなんか上手くいか
なくなってきてですね話が合わなくなって
きてそういうことじゃないだろうとかどう
してこういうことをが幸せなのにどうそう
いうことをしてくれないんだというような
ことで喧嘩になってしまったりとか
あるいはうまくいかなくなってしまう実現
できなくなってしまうってことがよある
わけです
でそこでですね
今日僕が皆さんと共有したい方法
アイディアというのはですねどのような
未来が幸せなのかということを言葉に
しようということです言葉にするだけです
ので今日家に帰っても0じゃでもできます
という話ですね何の道具もいりません話し
て自分で考えて話していけばいいという
ことになるわけです
そうすると
一つの言葉じゃなくてたくさんいくつも
言葉を作りますこういう未来がいいよね
こういうことが幸せだよねってことを言葉
にするとそしてそれをまああの話の中で
みんなでその言葉をつくってそれを共有
するとそういった未来にある
先にあるまだ来てない幸せがどういうもの
なのかっていうののイメージが共有できる
ようになりますもちろん絵が得意な人は会
で書くのもいいでしょうあるいは何か違う
表現でするのもいいと思いますでも言葉と
いうのは何の道具もいらずに話の中で普通
に会話の中で使うことができますしずっと
記憶の中にとどまってそれをずっと
持ち運ぶことができますなので今日お話し
た今その言葉幸せのカタチにハワイを
つけるということになります
ですねまぁちょっとこう抽象的に言っても
あのイメージがつかないかもしれないので
うちの家族でですねあの子供にですね
どんなときに幸せカップを聞いてみました
ポイントはですね未来の言葉を作っ作る
ポイントはどんな時が幸せかということを
自分に問うてみたり一緒にいる人に祈祷て
みたりする聞いてみるそういうとこから
始まります
で家にいる子どもたちにですねマドンナと
リア幸せという風に聞いてみました外いく
つが出てきますみんなで買い物してる時は
楽しいなぁと普通に家の近くのスーパーに
行くわけですけどその中で買い物してる時
は楽しいという答えが来ましたあそうなん
だとそうそうなんだねとドライブに出かけ
ている時とマナーこれは僕はちょっと想像
していましたがみんなでどっかま旅行に
行ったり近くのところへ遊びに行ったり
するそれは楽しいねと
あとはパパも一緒にテレビを見てみると木
という答えが返ってきましたこれは僕は
普段あの夜も含めてあちこちあの研究や
活動をしているのでなかなか一緒にテレビ
を見る時間ってのは限られているんです
けどもそういう時間が幸せなんだという
ことを改めて聞いてみて知ることができ
ましたでこういったことをよく見てみると
まぁ共通点があるんじゃないかなという
ことなんですねで今回お礼で見て僕が感じ
たのは家族で一緒にいるって言うこと一緒
に何かをするってことはあのすごく幸せだ
というふうに子供たちが感じているんだな
というふうに思いました僕もそう思います
なので家族と一緒っていう言葉を作りまし
たそうするとこれからですね何かをしよう
かと今週の土曜日日曜日なにしようかと
いう時に家族と一緒に何かをしようって
ことがまああの発想ができてそういうこと
を思いついてそれを提案したり話し合っ
たりすることができるわけです
もちろん家族の幸せということはそれだけ
に留まらなくてもっと色々話したことです
ね楽しい場所っていうのに入ったりすると
グラシアスだよねとか美味しいものを食べ
ている時は幸せだねとか新しい発見何か本
を読んだりいろんな何かを見に行って
新しい発見があるときも幸せ年とこういっ
たようなあのいくつかの要素で成り立って
いるいくつもの要素で成り立って言うなん
で1個だけたとえば家族でいっしょだけで
いいんだっていうことではなくてまあ
楽しい場所もあれば新しい発見の時もある
それが同時に起きることもあれば別々の日
に起きることもあるでもそういったことの
総体が全部まとめて幸せということを
形作っているとこういう言葉をつくろうと
いうことですこれが車合わせの形に名前を
つけると幸せというのは三角形であるとか
近くであるとか一言で言えるわけではない
んですねなのでいろんな言葉いろんな側面
からその幸せを自分たちで言葉にして自分
たちで定義をしていくということです
であの見てわかるとおり後に出てきた言葉
っていうのは別にある種
まあ当たり前というかそんなに特殊なこと
は入っていませんでもこれを自分たちで
作ったということに価値があります自分
たちの幸せの言葉の辞書は自分たちで作る
しかありませんなので自分たちで作って
それを自分たちで使っていくそういった
ことが未来に向かって自分たちの幸せの
未来を作っていく大切なあの一方なんです
その幸せのカタチ名前をつくれるという
ことが自分たちの幸せを幸せな未来を創る
まあ大きな一方となるということになり
ます
で僕は研究でこういったことをしていると
いうお話をしましたが今は家族の例ですが
例えば自分たちらしく生きていくとために
はですね自分たちだしたなんだろう自分
たちのしあわせって何だろう自分の幸せに
感じることを大切に思っていることって何
だろうっていうことをまああのみんなで
ですね考えて話し合っていく中で10分
らしさを見つけていくそういう
ワークショップを開いていますこれ先週
東京であの行ったワークショップなんです
が中学生ぐらいからあの大人まで参加して
みんなで自分たちらしさを自分で自分の
ことを考えるんですけどもその途中で
いろんな人と話しながらそれをまとめて
いくというそういうワークショップです
その1週間前には僕はですねブラジルにい
ましたブラジルというとちょうど地球の
反対側ですね日本の反対側ですブラジルで
同じようにワークショップをしました
ちょうど夏なんですけれどももっとオート
なたちがですね自分たちがしたって何
だろう自分が大切にしているものを知ら
せってなんだろうということをまああの
考えてこういうふうにまとめたりもしてい
ますこれ自分たちらしさなんですね
その他にも自分たちが理想とする幸せな
未来っていうのは自分たちの中の大切にし
てるものだけではなくてたとえばオフィス
自分たちが働く会社の環境がどんな風な
環境が良いだろうかということも話し合っ
て作ったりもしますこれは実際にオフィス
で皆さんは働いている皆さんがどういう
オフィスが幸せなんだろうか自分たちの
理想なんだろうかって事を話してを右下の
オフィスができたんですけれどもこういっ
た形で自分たちの理想の場を作るという
ことをしていますあるいはあの今新しい
カフェを作ろうとしていましてカフェを
利用する人やその供給をする人そうした人
たちにまああの音みんなでですねどんな
カフェなりそうなんだろうってことを考え
てその理想的な幸せなカフェをつくると
いうこともやっていますこれ来年オープン
します
その他ですねあのフューチャーセンター
ってのが最近いろいろなところにあるん
ですけれどもその未来を考えようっていう
そういう場がいろんな地域にでき始めてい
ますそのいろんな地域ででき始めている
フューチャーセンターというところで
例えばこれはですね農業の未来その地元の
農業をどうやってあのよくしていくかと
いうことを農家の方々と話していたりママ
さんたちが自分たちの子育てをしながら
働くそういった未来はどんなようなあり方
があるだろうということを話し合ってそれ
も言葉にしていますそれぞれです農業も
60個ぐらい新しい造語が鳥羽ができて
未来を語るための言葉ができましたし働き
方子育てしながら働くという生き方につい
ても5060くらいのそういったような
言葉ができてきますこういうことを研究で
やっているわけです
これはほかにもですねあの海外で自分たち
の専門的な分野の発展をどうやってやって
いくかという未来図をみんなで描くという
ことをこれは口がにアメリカで行ったもの
ですがこういった形で言葉にしていくと
本当にも34純の言葉ができて早速この日
からその一行の言葉を辞す実践しようと
いうことであの右下にいる彼が格好良くて
ですね未来は今から始まるんだと言って
ですねその日から実施実践をし始めたと
いうことをしていたりもします
こういうふうにですね自分たちがどういう
ものを理想とするのかっていうのは意外と
語ってないんですねあるいは館考える時間
ってのがなかなかなくて目の前の問題を
解決するとか過去の色々なことから勉強
しようとかですねそういうことが多くて
なかなか自分たちで自分たちの未来をこう
していきたいこういうのが理想だよねこう
いうことがしやすいだよねっていう時間と
いうのはなかなか日常の中ではありません
そういう機会が少ないです
なのでそこを話す時間を作りそれを言葉に
していくと言葉にするとみんながそれを
理解してそれをまあ共有して話し合って
そして明日もあさってもそれを覚えておく
ことができるということですこれが今日
あの僕がお話したかったことです
そうすると何がいいかということも
ちょっと最後まとめておきたいんですね
曖昧な未来のイメージが曖昧なままでは
なくて正五ツ屋10個の言葉そういった
言葉で成り立つようになるのでそうすると
その言葉を使って未来のイメージを形作っ
ていくことができると
でそのイメージを作ればそれに向かって皆
で動いていくことができるし何をしたら
いいかっていうことを考えることができ
ます
そして二つめ覚えておきやすくなると言葉
なのですごく簡単な家族と一緒家族で一緒
って言葉は簡単に覚えられます難しい専門
用語は何もありません自分たちでつくる
言葉なので自分たちで覚えていることが
できます
そして他の人と共有してそして話すことが
できるようになります言葉なのでいつでも
どんな時でもカフェでもあのご飯を食べ
ながらでもいつでもしゃべることができる
使うことができるそういったことがこの
メリットということになります
最後にですねあの女は大人の事例が続いた
ので最後に子どもたちの話なんですけれど
も僕の知り合いの東京コミュニティ
スクールというところであの子供たちが後
学んでいろんな事面白い事をやってるん
ですねでプロジェクトをやって自分たち
なりに何かを生み出していくということを
している学校です
この中で彼らがあの中うんたちが大切にし
ているものということをまとめましたそれ
が雑魚ども力という正少佐指示にですね
手書きの作った冊子でまとめられているん
ですけどこのなかから2つ紹介したいん
ですね一つはねじれても広がるというもの
です
これはあのいろんなアイデアを出していく
ときに何か話がねじれてなんか上手くいか
なくなっているかのように感じるんだけど
そこから広がりが出てくると単にパッと
思いついたアイデアじゃなくてちょっとグ
チャっとなったところからがまあ始まりだ
ということを彼らは根占ねじれても広がる
という言葉で表現しましたでこれが彼らの
大切にしていることの一つだと彼らはこの
自分たちが小学生の時に体験したことを
これからお隣なってもずっとねじれても
広がるって言うことを大切にしながら生き
ていけますしまた大人になったらもう
ちょっと違う表現に変わってくるかもしれ
ませんがこういったものを持って行くこと
ができます
あるいは変なのがいいとこれは僕大好きな
んですけども変なのがいい
で普通に方普通でそうじゃないかっていう
ことを考えた時に変だとちょっと嫌だなと
か変じゃなくて普通がいいと思いがちだ
けれども実は編っていうのは単に普通じゃ
ないだけじゃなくてとても新しかったり
面白かったりする可能性があるというなん
で逆みたいな形であの辺だということでは
なくてもうちょっと普通とは違う発想する
ことをむしろ僕たちは大切にしているんだ
ということを表現したわけです
これも同じようにやはり自分たちが大切に
している未来自分たちのいう大切にして
いることそれを言葉にした例だということ
になります
ということで今日僕がお話したかったこと
今日ぜひですねあの家に帰る途中でも帰っ
てからでもいいんですけれどもどんな時が
幸せかということを自分自身で考えてみ
たり家族や同僚お友達と話してみて欲しい
と思いますどんな時が幸せたとでどんな
ときは理想で何が良いと思っているのか
どんなことを大切にしているのかそういっ
たことをまず話し合うことから始めてそれ
を言葉にするということです幸せのカタチ
に名前をつける一つの名前ではなくて
たくさんの側面に一つ一つに名前を付けて
いく
この名付けるということはとても大切で僕
らの代替に持っている一緒には色んなもの
な前あるいは併用しはたくさん持ってます
同氏はありますでも自分たちの夢や理想と
して幸せというものにはあんまり言葉が
ないんですね日本語も英語もそうでしょう
そういったことを自分たちで自分たちの
未来に向かう辞書をつくっていくそれが僕
が今日皆さんにあの紹介したいあの広める
価値があるアイディアということになり
ますぜひ自分に何が幸せなのか東てみて
ぜひ家族友達とも話してみて欲しいと思い
ます以上ですどうもありがとうございまし
た